Hello and welcome to our
presentation on legal
knowledge graphs.
My name is Vaishali
I'm a Knowledge
Engineer at Legislate,
and in this presentation,
we will be discussing how
knowledge graphs are used in
the legal sector and how they
can be used with
documents in general.
As we all know,
knowledge graphs
have a variety
of applications
from technology
to retail because of their
flexible nature.
And we'll be exploring how and
why knowledge
graphs are useful
for legal documents
and explaining
some of their use cases.
So a bit about legislate.
Now legislate is a contract
management platform that makes
dealing with contracts easier
for all parties involved.
We were founded
in twenty twenty
because of how
long it takes to
make contracts
that often aren't
very complicated
and because of
the pain in negotiating
contracts.
So negotiating contracts can
often be difficult.
It can also it can often take
a lot of time and
there's often
a lot of back and forth that
happens with this.
It also usually requires,
a lawyer to go
through. So sorry.
The documents
the contracts need
to go through a lawyer,
which can often
be very costly,
But legislator
removes the need
for us to do this.
We're a team of eleven based
between Oxford and Seville,
and we consist of
a legal, technical,
and sales team.
Our aim is to make the end to
end contracting
process as simple
simple as possible for anybody
who decides to
use the platform
regardless of
their background.
One of the things that we've
come across is that contracts
often contain
a lot of legalese
and can be difficult
to understand.
So we're really
trying to reduce
the amount of legalese within
our contracts to
make them easy
to understand for anybody who
reads them.
So we and we aim to make our
contract as usable
as we can by
using knowledge graphs to,
connect contracts together and
make contracts easier to deal
with at scale.
So our current
customers consist
of small businesses
and property
managements, property managers
or letting agents
who deal with
contracts on a regular basis,
but can't necessarily justify
spending huge amounts of money
on a lawyer when
a lot of their
contracts are
a lot of the same
template, but tailored towards
individual, properties,
or individuals.
So they are often
exactly the same
with just some key
terms being changed.
And paying money for this or
paying a large amount of money
for this can often
seem, unnecessary.
So what we're trying to do is
make this as easy as possible
with legislate.
And so a bit about me,
I'm a knowledge
engineer at legislate.
I am primarily responsible for
dealing with knowledge graphs
and data
management surrounding
knowledge graphs.
So we're using
knowledge graphs
to organize our
data in the best
way possible so that we can
manipulate and
extract insights
from our data.
Knowledge graphs
have given us the ability to
navigate through
our data in a way
we never have before.
And one of the key things that
we've noticed is to ensure we
set up our data in the best
possible way so that it's easy
to look at, easy to
navigate through,
and it makes it as easy as
possible to get
the most out of it.
That's one of the main areas I
work work in,
and one of the main challenges
I'd say I've I've
been encountering
with knowledge graphs,
especially because
it's a new sector,
but I've really
enjoyed the process
of dealing with them.
So why do documents need to be
structured and linked?
So as you all know,
legal documents can be tedious
and difficult to
understand for
both humans and machines.
Generally, most
people will skim
through legal documents,
struggle to understand
the terminology.
They may not even
bother reading
the document properly.
And we're trying
to use knowledge
graphs to break down this
information to make it easier
to read for anybody
who is involved.
A lot of contract data is in
unstructured format and is in
unstructured formats,
and converting this
into a digital
computer readable
format can be
a challenge.
Businesses also can't always
rely on solely computers to do
this for them because
of the nature
of the documents,
because of the accuracy and
security of
the documents as well.
So for example, in,
in a industry
like healthcare,
the nature of the information
is often sensitive,
and you may not want you may
want some human
supervision over this.
And so using
knowledge graphs to,
automate this process,
but also have human input,
it really helps
make this a more
trustworthy process
for anybody
who decides to use it.
And contracts are not natively
machine readable,
which makes them difficult to
search and keep track of.
So by using knowledge graphs,
to organize this data,
we can make them
easier to follow.
Contracts are difficult to
understand and difficult to
understand in
an individual format.
And if we have
a hundred hundreds
of thousands of contracts,
that adds another layer of
complexity to this,
and that in itself is another
challenge to manage.
So if we can use
knowledge graphs
to better organize documents,
we can allow everybody to get
the most most out of their
documents and not worry about
what they're getting
themselves into.
So over here, we
just have a a little
diagram showing you
what the problems
with, documents can be.
So if we have one contract,
this is easy to,
this is easy to
process for a trained
human. So, generally,
somebody in the legal sector.
If we have a few,
this is manageable
for a trained human,
so somebody from
the legal sector.
But if we have
hundreds of them,
this is difficult
for even a somebody
from the legal sector.
It's, having a knowledge graph
to help make this
process easier,
makes it more manageable,
and makes it easy for anybody
to understand, not
just necessarily
a trained human.
So why should you structure
documents with
knowledge graphs?
So contracts contain highly
connected information,
and knowledge graphs can make
them easier to
process and search
at scale.
So contracts can
contain connected
fields. And as we all know,
knowledge graphs are flexible
and allow you to make links,
between nodes. So
using knowledge
graphs, we can
organize contracts
in a digestible and easy to
follow format and
use this data
in a variety of ways.
So, essentially,
knowledge graphs allow us to
organize contracts and break
them down into smaller chunks
that anybody can
understand and
use it in a variety of ways.
So over here, we
have an example
of a employment
offer letter and
an employment agreement.
So when you hire somebody,
you'd often be issuing
them an employment
offer letter and
an and an employment
agreement. But a lot of these
fields will be
exactly the same
across both
contracts or across
both legal documents.
The job title would
be the same.
The salary would be the same.
The line manager
would be the same.
And instead of having
to copy this over,
we could essentially just link
these two documents and copy
the fields over by
using knowledge
graphs.
So this is another diagram of
how we can link documents.
As I was saying,
when you hire an employee,
you will often issue an offer
letter and a employment
agreement.
And instead of
having two separate
documents that aren't linked,
we can use a graph,
which is natively
machine readable
and understandable.
It's also easy to search and
query to link
these documents.
So let's say this was our
employment agreement,
and this was our
offer letter.
Now these fields
might be the same.
So this might be
the salary field.
This might be the job title,
and this might be
the line manager.
We can then create
links between
these two contracts
because they
will contain the same
information.
And by linking them,
we make them easier
to search and query.
It's easier for an employer to
keep track of all
their employment
contracts and
keep track of all
their employment,
letters or contracts with with
a specific person and makes it
easier for them to
keep track of.
So reasoning is something that
also allows us to,
add more information into our
database and enrich our data.
So legal documents are
bound by the law,
and, hence, they
have rules they
need to follow in order
to be compliant.
This is where rule
based reasoning
can be useful
because we can use
it to validate contract data.
So legal documents,
may will have clauses,
and by using rule
based reasoning,
we can validate
the clauses that
are within
a document or ensure
that clauses are
written correctly
by using rule
based reasoning.
Rule based reasoning generally
uses an if then format,
whereby if the condition of
the rule is met,
then the latter
part of the rule
can be applied
to the dataset,
which can help us validate
contract data because we can
validate certain fields within
a contract. So
in an employment
agreement, we can
validate that
the salary field was there,
the job title
field was there,
benefits, and
insurance details
were there. We can also use
reasoning to connect contracts
as we've previously discussed
and infer new relationships
based on
the information available
to us.
Querying, as you all know,
is traditionally the way in
which you interact
with a knowledge
graph. So with reasoning,
querying then becomes really
insightful to us
because we can
use rules to
determine a lot to
predetermine a lot
of the information
that is tied to
our documents.
As you all know,
querying generally
uses sparkle
to interact with
the data store.
And based from based
off reasoning,
we can use sparkle to interact
with our data
store and the new
insights from rule
based reasoning.
One of the other things that I
think is quite
useful with rule
based reasoning
is it allows you
to act with the benefit
of hindsight.
So if you have access to your
data store, you
can look at all
the information
you have available
to you and, like I said,
enrich your data,
with further
relationships because
you now know what
you're dealing with,
and you can add
more relationships
into the data to
make it intuitive
to understand.
I also personally think that
sparkle and queries
are an intuitive
method of interacting
with data.
You're looking
for patterns and
relationships and
matching them up.
So using queries to interact
with your database can be easy
to pick up and easy
to understand,
which is something
I found as well,
when I first started working
with Agistay and working
with Monograph,
because I found the pattern
nature really easy
to follow and
easy to pick up.
And now we're gonna go through
some use cases of
using knowledge
graphs, in the legal
sector and
giving you some
examples of how
exactly this can work.
So we'll start with an easy
example and then work
our oh, whoops.
Sorry. And and then
work our way up.
So one of the easiest ways is
to ask questions and
retrieve answers.
And we can do this simply by
querying our database.
So it can be as
simple as asking
your database how many of our
contracts are
employment agreements.
And as I was saying previously
how we can add,
we can enrich our data with
the benefit of hindsight.
Here, we're asking
our database
how many contracts
are employment
agreements, but
we've added this
employment agreement class by
looking at all the contracts
that we have in our data store
and adding in further rules to
create classes and
enrich our data.
And although this can be done
by other databases,
this is a lot quicker with
knowledge graphs,
and we can use
the reasoning to
help clear up some
information.
We can also use queries to
calculate metrics.
So like like I've just said,
you can calculate
metrics using
other databases,
but we can make
this a lot quicker
with knowledge graphs,
and we can also provide users
with tailored metrics,
that are specific to them.
So this metric is
looking through
the database to
find all the active
teams within team two.
So it's looking for
all the contracts
that are a part of team two,
and then it's looking
for the start
and end dates attached
to the contract
and filtering for if the end
date is after
the date and time
right now and if
the start date
is before the date
and time right now.
We also have an optional field
for the end date.
So for a contract
like an employment
agreement, that may
not necessarily
have an end date
because an employee
can choose when they
wish to leave.
The end date is optional.
And so if the end
date isn't bound,
we just look for if the start
date is before
the date and time
right now. So that's
just a little
breakdown of what
this query is doing,
but then we can
then append this
information to
a metric and use
it wherever we like.
Building upon this,
we can also use
knowledge graphs
to provide users with contract
specific metrics.
So provide them with metrics
that are tailored to,
their contracts or to their
their dataset,
and this doesn't
necessarily have to
be an employment
metric. It can be
a property metric.
It can be a business
metric and
look at NDAs and
the average term.
This is just an example that
I've picked out.
So this metric is
for a given team,
it's looking for
the total salary
based on all
the contracts within
that team that
somebody has created.
And we can also
build a histogram
that automatically arranges
itself based on the values of
the contracts. So say we were
to hire another
team member who
has a salary of eighty
thousand pounds,
this histogram
will automatically
arrange itself,
to not only include
include them
in the in the distribution and
post very likely at the end of
this distribution, But,
this this distribution
here will
also rearrange itself,
to organize the data based on
the information
in the data set.
So it will work out the median
and the quartiles accordingly
based on the contracts within
the database, and,
it will re rearrange
itself accordingly,
which is really handy and just
makes sure that this this
information is
tailored to a user
and gives them all the insight
that they require.
As we've discussed
previously,
we can also use contracts to
validate contract structures,
and verify that contract
configurations are compliant,
with logical, legal,
and user defined
compliance rules.
So an employment
agreement, for example,
in order to be classified as
an employment agreement,
would need to
contain a salary,
a job title, a work location,
and a restriction period.
These are just some
examples of fields.
They can contain
more or less,
but these are some
of the fields
that would define the contract
to be an employment
agreement.
And this is important because
the employee needs
to know their
necessary obligations
as an employee,
and the employer is obligated
to provide them with
this information.
Using knowledge graphs
and reasoning,
we can verify if a particular
contract's if sorry.
Using knowledge graphs
and reasoning,
we can verify if a particular
contract should
have particular
clauses depending on the type
of contract it is,
and we can we can say whether
they should be
included or whether
they shouldn't be.
One of the last
use cases we can
have for knowledge graphs are
smart folders.
So using we can
further classify
our contracts by
using smart folders,
that automatically filter
contracts based
on active data.
So they'll filter through
documents by looking
at the information
inside them and,
organizing contracts
into folders
accordingly. So
they look through
your data and
they look for key
information and
they can filter
by a start date,
a particular line manager,
by contracts with
a specific individual,
by looking at contracts within
a specific year,
or by look by a group
of contracts,
with a company as
a specific party.
So it will look at the entries
of a contract and then make
these groupings accordingly.
It can connect contracts,
and it can draw insights that
would be time consuming to do
on our own without the use of
a knowledge graph
or rule based
reasoning. To do
this manually,
you'd have to look
at the contract
terms, analyze them,
and link them manually.
And using knowledge graphs,
this completely
removes the need
to do that.
So we've spoken about
some use cases,
and we're gonna
dive into another
example of how we can use
knowledge graphs,
which is by visualizing
contracts.
We've also spoken about how
contracts can be difficult to
understand and
difficult to read
through. And so once you have
access to the fields
of a contract
in a knowledge graph,
we can derive insights from
contract data to make it it
accessible to non lawyers.
And one of the ways we can do
that is to make the contract
more visual or to just simply
make the contract easier to
understand by presenting
the information
in another way.
So by storing the information
in a contract by its specific
contract fields,
we can easily access
the information
in these fields and use it in
multiple areas.
One of the examples of this is
that letting agents will often
provide their,
student let lets with a a key
information sheet that will be
provided based on
each individual
contract and tailored based on
each individual contract.
It might have
the key information
that student will
need to know,
such as when the rent is due,
how much late fees are,
how much notice is
given for reviewing.
And this could be
done via a template
that a letting agent may have
where they just simply replace
the information by
looking through
the the linked contract and
adding this information into
the template. But, again,
this would have to be edited
according to each
individual contract.
And using knowledge graphs,
we can make this
process a lot easier.
So using knowledge
graphs and reasoning,
we can derive this information
using domain expertise.
We can use reasoning to access
the information depending on
the type of field it's
being stored in.
So, basically, if we know what
type of contract
field a field is,
such as if it's
a salary field,
we can access the information
in this field, which will be
the entry to for
the salary, and,
use this in a variety
of formats,
either by visualization,
so by showing it
in a more visual
manner, or simply,
showing it in a partially
visual manner,
but a easy to
understand manner.
So that instead of
looking through
the whole contract,
a individual can just look at
the key summary,
the key summary fields and get
exact get the information that
they need.
And, yeah, this
can be presented
in any way, that
a user decides.
So this is just an example of
us showing you that,
we've got this information for
my knowledge graph.
This could be a string that is
just stored, and
then this value
is filled is sorry.
This value is
filled with the,
value from the contract.
And this is what will change,
according to each
individual contract.
And this is made a lot easier
using knowledge graphs,
because it can just look for
the the fields stored
within a contract
and change it accordingly,
which again ties
in with our aim
to make contracts
easier to understand,
and easy for anybody to deal
with no matter what
their background is.
So as we've discussed,
knowledge graphs have a number
of different
practical and helpful
uses in the legal sector,
and we've hope we've been able
we hope we've
been able to shed
some light on this.
It allows us to
extract insights
and information from
legal documents.
We can use rule
based reasoning
to infer new
relation relationships
or simply build
more relationships
into the graph
and make our data
more insightful.
Using rule based reasoning,
we can also get more
useful queries,
and interact with our data in
a more useful manner and find
exactly what it is
we're looking for.
Knowledge graphs
have the ability
to unlock so much
information,
and we've only just
touched on it.
But we hope to continue our
research and
explore this field
so that we can
make the best use
of them and really show what
knowledge graphs can do,
and what the what
their potential is.
Thank you for your time.
And if you have
any questions,
I'll be happy to take them.